that we're ready to chair
[Music]
okay thank you
uh okay well can i welcome everybody to
tonight's meeting of the licensing
subcommittee
um there is
all the attendances will be noted uh
when we're here just for the one item
which is the application for a review of
an existing premises license
astoria bar and grill
32-34 flixton road
ernst
um just by way of introductions i'm
councillor german i'm chair of the panel
i've got with me count councillors
thomas and butt
um we have a licensing officer legal
officer a governance officer
and i think all the rest of them have
been introduced have been introduced
previously
we have had um apart from the bundle
which we received about a week ago which
was quite substantive
we have a couple of late submissions
today one
from the licensee in response to
the police proposed conditions and one
from the licensing manager just giving
the times of the various
premises and and
some of the
conditions relating to door stuff mainly
uh just just the one sheet one page
has everybody had a chance to uh to read
and digest that and they're they'll be
all happy with that
uh yeah yeah yeah we're real happy to
proceed
yeah right so
right so let's go through the order of
the meeting first i'll ask the licensing
officer uh to give a background to the
review application
um i believe we have a dvd to watch
which is
part of the police evidence which is
approximately 55 minutes long
um
and for that we have to switch off the
live streaming because of gdpr issues
because it identifies members of the
public uh do not have their permission
if anybody would like to ask a question
about the content of the dvd while it is
playing if they just ask for it to be
stopped and then
they can ask the question but there will
be an
opportunity to ask questions at the end
then i'll ask um
the police to explain why they wanted
the review and
why the why we should
adopt the conditions that they're asking
us to
there will then be questions which will
be in the order of the members officers
and the licensee and the representative
then i'll ask the licensee and the
representative to
respond each of us are 15 minutes by the
way
and there'll be questions in the order
of members officers and
the police
ask both parties to summarize
starting with the licensee and then the
gnp
the both parties will have two minutes
to summarize
um the panel will retire to a breakout
room to make the decision and then when
we made that decision which might might
take a bit of time
and we'll we'll come back to uh to
deliver the decision
now
i realize it it's probably going to be
quite a long meeting tonight so if
anybody wants a comfort break if they
please say so i might may well impose
one at some point anyway depending on
how it goes
so
if we're all happy
to proceed on that basis can i ask the
licensing officer to uh to give a
background to the review
um
i'm sorry to introduce to this stage but
just in relation to the timings
was i write that you that you said that
questioning of um
of gmp would be restricted to 15 minutes
for each party because i think with
respect to there's potentially a lot of
matters i i would need to
to um ask questions on and i'm not
confident i'd be able to do that in 15
minutes given the the size of the bundle
and the the material that's been served
no the the presentation for for the gmp
and yourself
would be restricted to 15 minutes but
the questions are not actually
restricted
it's up to me
they're going on too long but we
have no i appreciate that freedom
flexibility with that
so uh thank you
okay
would you like to present the uh
while we're here tonight please
thank you chair um
as stated in the report um at any stage
following the grant of a premises
license a responsible authority such as
the police or fire authority or an
interested party such as a resident may
ask the licensing authority to review
the license because our matter arising
at the premises in connection with any
of the full licensing objectives
on the 9th of december 2021 the
licensing authority received such an
application from greater manchester
police
requesting a review of the premises
license held by shaw leisure holding
limited for premises known as astoria
bar and grill
32-34 flixton wrote earnston
on the grounds of preventing crime
disorder and ensuring public safety
a copy of the application is attached at
appendix a to the report for the members
and a copy of the police evidence in
support of that application
is attached to appendices b and c
in respect of the notice of the
application the notice was posted
outside the premises at the council's
offices and on the council's website in
accordance with the relevant regulations
a notice was also given to all
responsible authorities
the authority received two
representations during the 28-day notice
period one from the council's pollution
and housing team
and the other from the council's trading
standards team
representations recommended the addition
of further conditions and the amendment
of two existing conditions attached to
the license
premises license health has agreed to
conditions with both the pollution and
trading standards team and the details
of those agreed conditions are attached
um to the report
as you um refer
um
as you referred to uh chair the
authority did receive a statement from
mr shaw's representative yesterday in
respect of the conditions proposed by
the police confirming the conditions to
which
um he would agree and those he would not
agree to and why
and a copy of that statement has been
forwarded to the members
for their information a copy has also
also been sent to the police
um the members are now being asked to
consider the application and any
relevant representations and take such
steps as it considers necessary for the
promotion of the licensing objectives
the options available to the
subcommittee are to modify the
conditions of the premises license
to exclude a licensable activity or
activities from the scope of the license
to remove the designated premises
supervisor
to suspend the license for a period of
not exceeding three months or to revoke
the license
as you say chair as part of the evidence
bundle
the police have submitted a dvd with
footage showing incidents which took
place um inside and outside the premises
during the period under review
and footage just show images of
individuals who could be identified and
is recommended
um in order to comply with gdpr rules
the subcommittee temporarily exclude the
public from the meeting whilst it views
the footage
and then reopens the meeting to continue
the hearing so that's all i propose to
say to introduce the mata chair um the
footy
foot of footy the footage
fingers crossed is ready to view once
the public have been excluded
thank you ms boyle does anybody first of
all have any questions for uh the
licensing officer
any qualification or anything else
uh no questions
no okay um in that case can i ask uh
natalie could you switch the live
streaming off and
could you uh screen share the uh the dvd
please